if you want to know how our leaders plan
to transform this country it's not
enough to look at the millions of
foreigners from the third world that
they're importing into the country every
year that's obviously one of the most
important parts of what they're doing
and it's clearly deliberate we have
border patrol agents literally fist
bumping illegal migrants on camera and
uh cutting the fence for them but at the
same time it's also important to take a
look at the kinds of people the
government is expelling from the country
so don't just focus on who they're
importing although so that's very
important look at who they're exporting
arbitrarily and by force and if you do
that you'll learn a lot about the
ideologies that our government truly
cannot stand you'll discover what they
desperately want to destroy as quickly
and completely as they can so here's a
case that tells you everything you need
to know on that front just a few weeks
ago without any warning the Biden
Administration decided to deport the
Rica family that they've been living in
the state of Tennessee for the past 15
years this is a family that unlike the
illegal immigrant drunk drivers and
violent felons that the Biden
Administration will defend at every
opportunity um has not committed any
crime so what did they do well back in
2006 you and Hannah lore Romo were
living in Germany and they decided they
wanted to homeschool their five children
because they're Christians and they were
upset about the perverted and satanic
books and curriculum that their kids
were being forced to read and were being
subjected to in schools which you know
may sound familiar based on the
experiences of lots of parents in this
country but in Germany um homeschooling
was not allowed there's a Nazi era law
in Germany which is still in effect of
this state that bans homeschooling in
the vast majority of cases so officials
in Germany started finding the rikas for
uh more than what they earn in a year uh
because they were trying to homeschool
their kids police officers showed up and
dragged their kids to school they they
threatened to take the children away
permanently so the Rica family had a
decision to make and to protect their
children you and Han Mica fled to the
United States back in
2008 now initially an immigration judge
approved their request for Asylum uh but
the Obama ministration appealed that
decision ultimately a federal appeals
court told the family that they had to
leave the United States and return to
Germany this is report on what happened
this is from a decade ago this is back
when all this first started let's watch
that the appeals court upheld the Obama
administration's refusal of Asylum to
the romica family the Romas fled Germany
in 20 08 facing criminal prosecution for
homeschooling they live in Tennessee in
2010 they were granted political assylum
by an immigration judge but that
decision was overturned by the board of
immigration appeals last year and
Tuesday the three-judge panel of the
sixth circuit issued a unanimous
decision against the family UVA and
holor Rica began homeschooling in
Germany because they didn't want their
children exposed to things like
Witchcraft and graphic SE education that
are taught in German schools also there
were stories where they were encouraged
to ask the devil for help instead of God
and actually the devil would help and we
found out what is in the
textbooks uh it's exactly the opposite
from what the Bible tells us and teaches
us and we wanted to protect
them so they're good parents in other
words they're good parents and they care
about their kids uh can't have those
types around here Canen we now after
this decision uh was made to deport the
family and after it was upheld in courts
there was an enormous public outcry as
you might imagine so the DHS under the
OB Obama administration did something
unexpected they allowed the ricas to
stay in this country in 2013 the feds
granted the family something called
indefinite deferred action status and
that allowed them to work and to live in
the United States without fear of
deportation and without any timetable
for leaving so they were you know uh for
all intents and purposes they were free
and clear that was their arrangement for
a decade and during this period the
rachas had two more children uh both of
whom were born in the United States but
then on September 6th of this year
during a routine check-in all of this
changed the ricas learned that their
deferred status was coming to an end for
some reason the bid administration had
decided that they were going to DET
terminate they were going to terminate
that status and they weren't given a
reason there's no reason for this they
were just told it's over you got to
leave and they were told told that they
had four weeks to get German passports
and that they'll be deported on October
11th which is next week now just so you
you know because you might be wondering
well well did they do something did
something happen um no nobody in the
Rica family did anything to trigger this
change in the federal government's
reasoning all that's happened is that
the Biden Administration has decided
that they want to end their deferred
status out of the blue
watch their argument was we've got a
well-founded fear of persecution by
Germany because we're in this particular
social category of homeschoolers Kevin
Bowden and The Homeschool legal defense
Association helped the Rica's fight in
court an appeals court ruled against
their Asylum they have not shown that
Germany's enforcement of its General
School attendance law amounts to
persecution against them the judge wrote
and they're here with the approval of
the US government but without permanent
residency U says immigration agents
asked him and his family to get German
pass ports ready to self-deport know we
will be faced the same situation same
kind of persecution two of his children
are married to American citizens two
others were born
here he says the hardest part is not
knowing what's next we don't have any
place to live there uh I don't have any
work to provide for my family over
[Music]
there now the ricas have stayed here
since that ruling through an
understanding with ice they're required
to check in with immigration agents
every 6 months to a year now they say
they're working with their attorneys to
figure out what's next John Robin thank
you so a federal court uh ruled a decade
ago that this family doesn't technically
qualify for Asylum even though they're
in a really difficult position and
whether you agree with that ruling or
not it really doesn't matter even if we
concede for the sake of arguments that
this family doesn't have a legitimate
Asylum claim the fact remains that the
Biden Administration has spent the last
several years refusing to deport
millions of illegal aliens who clearly
don't have any legitimate basis for
Asylum and by the way I say for the sake
of argument we can concede it I
personally do not concede that by the
way it's obvious to me that if you flee
a country because you're being
persecuted for exercising your basic
human right to educate your own children
you are in every sense a legitimate
Asylum Seeker so to me it's quite
obvious that this is a legitimate case
of asylum and especially you know in a
in a country where we're told that
you're being persecuted if somebody uses
a pronoun you don't like in your
presence well I think the government
coming in and and and dragging your
children away and say we're to take your
children away permanently if you don't
send them to our indoctrination camps to
learn
Satanism yeah that's uh that's a case
for Asylum people always say happy dog
happy life well you know if that's
really the case you need to be giving
your dog rough greens naturopathic Dr
Dennis black the found of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America little did I know
before I got rough greens dog food is
dead food everybody knows that nutrition
isn't Brown it's green well let rough
greens boost your dog's food back to
life rough greens is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
grain it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for our dogs too naturopathic
Dr Dennis black is so confident Ru
greens will improve your dog's health
he's offering my listeners a free jump
start trial bag so your dog can try it a
free jump start trial bag can be at your
door in just a few business days go to
Ru greens.com mat or call 844 ru700
that's rfg greens.com or call 844 ru700
today well you know a company is looking
out for you when they actually upgrade
your service and don't charge you for it
this is great news for new and current
Pure Talk customers pure talk just added
data to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but haven't made the switch
take a look again for just $20 a month
you'll get unlimited talk text to now
50% more 5G data plus their new mobile
hotspot this is why I love Pure Talk
they're veteran-owned and only hire the
best customer service team located right
here in the great USA most families are
saving almost $1,000 a year while
enjoying the most Dependable 5G Network
in America remember you vote with how
you spend your money so stop supporting
woke wireless companies that don't
support you when you go to P talk.com
Walsh you'll save an additional 50% off
your first month because they actually
value you that's Pur talk.com Walsh Pure
Talk Wireless for Americans by Americans
but the point is that we already open
our arms to many illegal immigrants who
have no claim to Asylum at
all you know in many cases we're talking
about criminals who came here simply
because they want to make more
money and these criminals enjoy Total
Protection on the B the Biden
Administration in fact Joe Biden himself
is on record saying that he wants ice
agents fired if they deport illegal
aliens who who come here and then get
caught drunk driving watch they go off
to school wondering whether when Mom
comes and Picks Them Up is she not going
to be there because an ice agent was
there to arrest her or they take he she
takes him to the doctor that she's going
to not be there because she is quote
undocumented and nice agent is going to
pick him up so how do you change the
culture you change the culture by saying
you're going to get fired you're fired
if in fact you do that you only arrest
for the purpose of dealing with a felony
that's committed and I don't count drunk
driving as a
felony he doesn't count it as a felony I
mean the the courts in many cases
disagree but he does you know it's just
drunk driving it's just you know you're
intoxicated getting behind the wheel of
the car of a car and you could easily
kill somebody not a big
deal so so if you come here from Haiti
or El Salvador and then having broken
our laws to enter the country in the
first place you proceed to get
completely wasted and endanger American
citizens on the road Joe Biden thinks
you shouldn't have to fear deportation
and on top of that he thinks that any
federal agent who even contemplates
deporting you should lose their
job but ice has no problem going after
the
ricas and none of the ice officers
telling this family that they're about
to be deported are worried about getting
being fired by Joe
Biden because they're following orders
this law-abiding hardworking Christian
family is dangerous apparently according
to the Biden government we got to get
them out not the illegal immigrants who
come here and they're and they're
getting drunk and driving around and
killing people not them um we need to
get this family
out they're they're law Breakers because
of some technicality with Asylum
procedure the family patriarch who works
as a piano companists at a at a small
private university in Tennessee is a
threat somehow but you know the drunk
drivers who could wipe out your whole
family well we need to protect them at
all costs that that that's what they're
saying basically now it's so absurd on
its face that you have to conclude that
something else is going on here and what
might that be well the other day one of
the many ghouls at the left-wing
propaganda outfit Media Matters said the
quiet part out loud of course it usually
not usually it's not worth paying any
attention to Media Matters Most of the
time they're a partisan Soros funded
operation that exist to defame and smear
their political opponents that's all
they do but as a window and also they
exist to promote the daily wire and
that's the part that we like but as a as
a window on what the B the Biden
government and their allies are planning
it can be useful to check in on Media
Matters and outfits like that every now
and again so with that in mind here's
what one of the Media Matters hacks who
uses the name Ary drenan posted the
other day on uh Twitter quote hot take
but unless you have a very good reason
homeschooling should be illegal too many
parents use it to abuse their children
keeping them ignorant and easy to
control now drenan was responding to a
video of a child pointing out that Joe
Biden sniffs children and how disgusting
that is and of course any reasonable
well-adjusted child would agree that
it's disgusting that this old man sniffs
children but that makes Joe Biden look
bad so AR drenan couldn't let it stand
and in the process the quiet part was
uttered out loud which is this many on
the left especially the LGBT left have
hated homeschooling for a long time
because they see it as a direct attack
on their ability to indoctrinate the
next generation of
Americans and by the way they're right
about that it is a direct attack on
their ability to do that so they want to
Outlaw homeschooling just like they did
back in Germany in
1938 they'll accuse you of child abuse
if you resist their
indoctrination and ultimately they'll
try to take your children
away and then they'll do it on some
pretense that you know which is which is
actually very funny that homeschooled
children uh they're be they're being
kept ignorant they're not being well
educated meanwhile the the government
education system is churning out high
school graduates who can barely
read you know who can't point to their
own country on a map and we're churning
these people out every single year by
the
thousands but homeschooling that's the
real
problem and that's what this is really
about it's it's about the the agenda
against homes it's hard to imagine
another reason why the Biden
Administration could possibly want to
deport the rikas the truth is obvious
they want to take out a symbolic
target white Christians who won't do
what they're told who won't surrender
their children to the perverse
propaganda that the B Administration
endorses are the enemy of this
regime and now they're very publicly
being shown the door this is a precursor
to what they're planning for the rest of
us it's also once again a chance for the
bid Administration to humiliate its Poli
itical enemies I mean the ricas have
seven children one of them is married to
an American citizen named Trace Bates
and according to the Tennessee and Trace
Bates reading now quote Trace Bates was
photographed with his brother in crowds
at a prot trump protest in Washington on
January 6 2021 trace's brother Lawson
Bates said on social media that the two
attended a pro Trump event in
Washington's uh ellipse Park but were
not part of the riot at the US capital
so the point is this family definitely
doesn't have the right Politics As far
as Biden is concerned
now if they had torched a Wendy's on
behalf of BLM maybe they could stay but
they like Donald Trump at least some in
the family do I don't know what all
their politics are and they question the
uh sacred legitimacy of our infallible
elections so they have to go they have
to uproot their lives and move halfway
across the world leaving half of their
family in the United
States what's interesting about this is
um back when the Trump Administration
tried to end the Obama era DCA policy
courts ruled that Trump didn't have the
authority to do it why well because they
said all those illegal migrants had come
to rely on Barack Obama's decision so
even though what Barack Obama did was
illegal even though daaka was
unconstitutional all of those illegal
immigrants had to stay in the country
they were entitled to rely on what
Barack Obama promised them the promise
was made and so the promise had to be
kept that was the logic but apparently
the ricas don't get that luxury
even though promises were made to
them maybe they should have gotten DUIs
and voted Democrat if they wanted to
stay here then probably would have
changed things it's hard to see exactly
what happens next in the orica's case
lawmakers in Congress right now are
working on legislation that might let
them stay in this country they're
obviously taking this through the court
system you know so this is not this Saga
is far from over but as a sign of where
things are going the implications are
pretty
clear these people do not believe you
have the right to educate your children
they think that's their job not just
their job but their right they have the
right uh they have a right to your
children they own your
children that's why the Biden doj opened
up federal counterterrorism
investigations because of parents
complaining at Schoolboard meetings it's
why Joe Biden surrogate Terry McCulla
said infamously uh quote I don't think
parents should be telling schools what
they should teach it's why California
just tried to pass a law saying parents
could lose custody of their kids if they
don't affirm their quote unquote gender
identity and it's why now the bid
Administration wants to send the ricas
back to Germany where they're certainly
almost certainly going to be prosecuted
by the way you know a few minutes ago I
said that we're uh importing foreigners
and Anarchy from the third world but
really it's worse than that we are
specifically rewarding thousands of
Haitians and Guatemalans and Africans
who endanger their own children in their
effort to cross the border rewarding
them and at the same time we exporting
hard-working white Christians who care
more about their children than anything
else in the
world wrong politics wrong race so they
have to go we are governed by
politicians who hate children as much as
they want to control
them and whatever happens to the ricas
that that's all very clear and like the
ricas we really have only one choice in
response to this which is to disobey
whatever the consequences the
alternative surrendering our children to
these
scumbags is much worse if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there godp
speed